vou falar um pouquinho sobre
empreendedorismo na amazônia
empreendedorismo é um tema que
normalmente nós associamos mais ao sul
do país ou ao vale do silício outros
lugares
eu queria propor que a amazônia é palco
do mais interessante experimento de
empreendedorismo dos últimos 50 anos no
brasil
vou falar um pouquinho sobre o estado de
rondônia
vocês vão se perguntar puxa porque
rondônia que rondônia tem a ver com o
empreendedorismo bem em 1970 com dona
tinha cerca de 100 mil habitantes
hoje rondônia tem um milhão e 800 mil
habitantes é o estado nesse período que
mais cresceu na nossa nação e o que
aconteceu ali nos anos 70
os militares tinham uma visão de ocupar
a amazônia e tinha aquele lema antigo de
agentes em terra para uma terra sem
gente e com isso eles trouxeram milhares
de pequenos agricultores que eu vou
chamar de pequenos empreendedores vieram
na sua maioria do paraná santa catarina
pobres sem terra e foram transferidos
dali do sul do país por meio da amazônia
trazidos na br 364 é beque naquela época
ainda nem asfaltada era foram lançados a
partir de ônibus ao mato
eles foram lançados informados olha essa
terra daqui a sua
se você desmatar 80% dessa terra você
vai ganhar esse título aos milhares eles
vieram para a amazônia são verdadeiros
imigrantes gente pensa em imigrante como
alguém que troca de país mas alguém que
troca o sul do brasil pela amazônia é um
migrante plus imigrante quase um outro
planeta eles vieram e o que aconteceu
bem eu vou pular 50 anos de história em
2013 eu tive em ariquemes uma pequena
cidade média cidade em rondônia com o
agora ex-ministro mangabeira unger
fazendo uma consultoria para o estado de
rondônia e numa sala na associação
comercial tinha cerca de 300 pecuaristas
e nós fizemos a pergunta pra eles
quantos de vocês tem mais de mil
hectares e mais ou menos dois terços
deles levantaram a mão e o que isso quer
dizer
um hectare em rondônia ele vale no
mínimo cerca de três mil reais
então nós tínhamos nessa sala cerca de
200 multimilionários todos eles com
origem naquele pobres pequenos sem terra
a agricultores que vieram a primeira
geração a segunda geração que vieram do
paraná
não há nenhum outro caso na história do
brasil do governo se aliando não com os
grandes empresários mas com os pequenos
com aqueles pequenos empreendedores
ocupando um território ocupando uma nova
fronteira e transformando uma região de
100 mil para um milhão e oitocentos e
uma região com algumas peculiaridades
dentro da amazônia por exemplo os
índices de pobreza em rondônia hoje são
muito inferiores à igualdade social a a
a disparidade entre classes lá é muito
menor do que no restante da amazônia
muito parecida por exemplo o estado de
minas gerais há muitos anos mas ocupado
um outro item interessante aqueles
empreendedores aqueles que chegaram eles
chegaram muito provavelmente sem
educação sem muito conhecimento mas com
a faca nos dentes
buscando a vida querendo crescer a
segunda geração hora a segunda geração
vem melhor ainda
o estado de rondônia por incrível que
pareça é o estado com
a maior proporção de universidades
privadas universidades faculdades
privadas per capta do brasil são cerca
de uma para cada 53 mil pessoas
o segundo estado que eu encontrei
fazendo a conta foi santa catarina com
uma para cada 91 mil pessoas só
extraordinário indicador de que o estado
tem uma grande promessa frente a partir
daqueles milhares de empreendedores que
em ariquemes eram 200 se você contar o
estado todo
são milhares agora o que houve
o que houve de ruim nessa experiência
essa experiência foi uma experiência do
século 20 quando não se havia ainda no
brasil uma consciência ambiental
então o resultado é que rondônia é hoje
o estado mais desmatado da federação
está mais desmatada da amazônia cerca de
29% e desmatamento enquanto a média
quando a média é de 17
então o que nós precisamos nós
precisamos repensar amazônia repensar o
empreendedorismo na amazônia no contexto
do século 21
tentar pegar toda essa energia do
empreendedorismo que transformou o
estado transformou uma sociedade e fez
com que ela fosse relativamente próspera
em apenas 40 anos e revertê la para a
amazônia no século 21
eu vou dar alguns exemplos bem o que dá
pra fazer com um por cento da amazônia
mas hoje está digamos 17 18% desmatada
que daria pra gente fazer um por cento
dela
se a gente pegasse 1% e dedicar-se à
piscicultura apicultura hoje usando as
melhores técnicas usando tecnologia ela
consegue gerar cerca de 10 toneladas de
proteína por hectare
vocês terem uma idéia a pecuária é a
pecuária extensiva tradicional na
amazônia ela consegue produzir no máximo
300 quilos de proteína por ano aqui
são 30 vezes mais produtividade em um
hectare
se você pegasse um por cento da amazônia
e você cobrisse com psicultores por
todos os lados e é só 1% o que você
teria você teria 50 milhões de toneladas
de peixes
isso é equivalente a um pouco mais da
metade da produção de peixes do mundo só
com um por cento da amazônia
se você pegasse esse mesmo 1% amazonas
dedicasse ao manejo florestal
sustentável manejo florestal sustentável
você extrai você divide uma área em 25
pedaços explora um pedaço por ano e é ao
final de 25 anos você volta pra aquele
primeiro pedaço que já se regenerou e
você extrai cerca de 10 a 20 por cento a
biomassa então não é nenhum desmatamento
muito profundo com um por cento da
amazônia voltado ao manejo florestal
sustentável você poderia gerar renda e
cerca de 17 bilhões de reais o
suficiente para levar a inter às
populações da pobreza e gerar uma
economia próspera
por outro lado o que o que custa
proteger um por cento da amazônia
nós temos já há casos menciona aqui a
experiência de uma instituição de uma
fundação a fundação amazonas sustentável
que com um orçamento de cerca de 15
milhões de reais por ano
consegue proteger com competência cerca
de 2% na amazônia isso já está
acontecendo hoje é os índices de
desmatamento nessas áreas são ínfimos
comparados com o grau de desmatamento
que ainda ocorre no país
então se você pegasse essa experiência e
levasse ela pra todas as áreas de
conservação que estão já estabelecidas
na amazônia que cobre cerca de 40%
amazônia isso custaria 300 milhões de
reais
parece muito dinheiro parece mas é só
meio por cento dos orçamentos dos
governos dos estados da amazônia sem
considerar municípios sem considerar o
governo federal então
é uma questão de decisão todas essas
frentes para desenvolvimento e
conservação estão ao nosso alcance
já hoje parece fácil
parece que dá aí quais os problemas
eu fiz parte de um governo anterior
quando nós estabelecemos um manejo
florestal sustentável como um dos focos
é e foram estabelecidos cerca de 2 mil
pequenos planos de manejo espalhados
pelo estado tentando criar esses digamos
2 mil empreendedores na amazônia
isso foi feito de 2005 a 2009 em 2012
é eu comecei a me envolver de novo com
manejo florestal depois de sair do
governo do estado com uma startup uma
startup estilo silicon valley vale do
silício mas está com a boca pra tentar
transformar o manejo florestal em algo
próspero que pudesse crescer em ritmo
acelerado
essas duas iniciativas do governo e da
iniciativa privada as duas foram pro
buraco e elas foram pro buraco porque
morreram de inanição e nani são todos
motivos principais
ou as dificuldades logísticas da
amazônia que é muito caro transportar
qualquer coisa dentro da amazônia onde
não há bons portos onde não há boa
estrutura mas mais do que isso
questões de burocracia nós fomos
enterrados em uma montanha de papel
desde a secretaria de fazenda as
secretarias de meio ambiente para
terminar
eu queria falar se quatro coisas que são
necessárias para o futuro da amazônia
para que esse futuro usando só 1%
amazônia que você consiga prosperar que
você consiga criar aqui sociedades ricas
não só a nível de subsistência mas
sociedade fica de classe média
primeiro nós precisamos de mais
empreendedores estão mais gente assim
como rondônia teve
nós precisamos de mais gente com vontade
empreendedora acho que todos aqui tem um
pouco desse espírito você
então aqui é mas nós precisamos
multiplicar isso por mil por 10 mil
o segundo item a burocracia experiência
do brasil precisa ser reduzido brasil já
teve um ministério da desburocratização
eu acredito que a gente precisa de novo
de gente pensando em reduzir os
empecilhos aos empreendedores são os
empreendedores que nos levam pra frente
é não é o governo
o governo vem a reboque paz nós
precisamos estimular esses
empreendedores para andarem mais rápido
terceiro ciência e tecnologia
quando falava de piscicultura hoje
piscicultura é tenha produtividade 10
toneladas por hectare
há dez anos atrás esse número era cerca
de seis toneladas por hectare
então nós conseguimos ganhar 50% e
produtividade com melhores técnicas com
melhores espécies com com melhores
razões
isso tudo estudado grande parte fruto do
trabalho do inpa e de outras
instituições embrapa e outras
instituições mais que tem trabalhado
nessa frente mas precisamos de mais
nós queremos nós podemos chegar a 10
podendo chegar a 10 podem chegar a 15 e
aí a equação econômica muda e nós nos
tornamos muito mais competitivos e por
último questões de logística na amazônia
são complexos imagine você produzir
peixe distante de manaus é muito caro
trazer até manaus vai ser inviável
se você tiver melhor esporte se você
tiver melhores estruturas estudo vai ser
possível
eu queria terminar dizendo que pra fazer
tudo isso funcionar
a gente precisa provavelmente do recurso
renovável é mais abundante que existe no
brasil povo brasileiro acha que é único
ele tem um grau de vitalidade diferente
dos outros pontos então o o o recurso
renovável do espírito humano da vontade
de prosperar a vontade de crescer a
vontade de ter um país melhor para os
seus filhos
esse recurso renovável abundante precisa
ser aplicado com maior intensidade na
amazônia
obrigado